syrians first heard sabah fakhri's tenor  when he was a child  calling muslims to prayer at a mosque in  aleppo  during his 70-year career he revitalized  classical arabic music fans adored his  charisma and his endurance on stage in  1968 he sang for 10 hours to a crowd in  caracas venezuela and made it into the  guinness world records  fakhri once told an interviewer he came  out of the womb singing his family used  to pinch him just to hear him cry  because they loved that booming sound  arab poets from centuries past for  lyrics the singer was patriotic and said  his syrian heritage deeply influenced  his  music performed across continents during  his career bringing traditional arabic  music to audiences far from the middle  east  hearing the news of his passing one  kuwaiti composer said the melody of  aleppo  and the light of music went out in the  levant